und wieder gibt es zweifel an der dunkle
materie in 65 millionen lichtjahren
entfernung wurde einen zwerg galaxie
gefunden die sich komplett anders
verhält als alle anderen bisher
gefundenen galaxien sie enthält nämlich
keine beziehungsweise trauben dunkle
materie wenn es sie denn gäbe also
wieder ein gegenbeweis der dunkle
materie und warum jetzt diejenigen die
eine andere theorie als die dunkle
materie für die bewegung der galaxien
haben probleme haben also dass jetzt
alles bei klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen ngc 1052 tf2 das ist
der name der seltsamen zwerggalaxien
eigentlich eine ganz normale galaxie
aber mit einer besonderheit im vergleich
zum beispiel zu unserer milchstraße
enthält sie 250 mal weniger sterne eine
ganz besondere klasse von galaxien diese
klasse ist durchsichtig man sieht die
galaxien dahinter sie gehört zur klasse
der ultra diffusen galaxien die
überhaupt erst vor wenigen jahren
entdeckt wurde
zitat ich habe eine stunde lang nur auf
dieses bild gstaad das sagt pieter van
dokkum von der yale university
er hatte die galaxien eine aufnahme des
hubble weltraumteleskops entdeckt und da
wurde pieter van dokkum neugierig sein
forschungsteam untersuchte 10
kugelsternhaufen der galaxien er und
stellte verblüffendes fest anders als
bei allen anderen galaxien waren die
bewegungen dieser sternenhaufen komplett
durch die vorhandene materie zu erklären
sprich dort gibt es keine oder nur sehr
wenig dunkle materie maximal können sie
ein vier hundertstel der materie in der
galaxie seien bei 300 millionen
sonnenmassen ist das weniger als eine
million sonnenmasse absolut lächerlich
und dem kosmologischen standardmodell
zuwider laufen dementsprechend es rund
27% dunkle materie neben der noch
angenommen 70 prozent dunkler energie
sein müssten
da die sichtbare materie im
standardmodell nur drei prozent ausmacht
dürften es nicht ein 400 zu sein also
025 sondern im vergleich zur normalen
materie 1000 also das 4000 fache dass es
wirklich absolut verrückt hier stimmt
einfach etwas überhaupt gar nicht zitat
eine galaxie ohne dunkle materie
kommt wo uns völlig überraschend sie ist
eigentlich der wichtigste teil jeder
galaxie der diese zusammenhält sagt
stellt alle gängigen theorien auf den
prüfstand meint van dokkum bisher galt
es als sicher dass dunkle materie
überhaupt erst die entstehung von
galaxien ermöglicht erst sie soll die
sichtbare materie anziehen und zur
verklumpung zu sternen und planeten
führen aber ngc 10 52 - df 2 zeigt das
gegenteil demnach würde diese theorie
gar nicht stimmen und noch eine andere
schwierigkeit gibt es und zwar für
diejenigen die das universum ohne dunkle
materie erklären wollen
obst wenn diese galaxie die sich
komplett anders verhält dann dann ist es
unmöglich ein neues modell der
gravitation ohne dunkle materie zu
entwickeln es würde in dieser galaxie
einfach nicht funktionieren
jetzt sucht das forschungsteam nach
weiteren galaxien ohne dunkle materie
und bis dahin bleiben nur spekulationen
denn diese zwerggalaxien ist auch in
anderer hinsicht seltsam keine galaxie
name kein richtiges zentrum und jetzt
kommt es kein super massereiches
schwarzes loch im zentrum das alles
führt mich ja zurück zur theorie der
schwarzen löcher als der dunkle materie
erinnert euch die beschreibung von
dunkler materie und schwarzen löchern
ist nahezu gleich nur dass wir schwarze
löcher kennen die theorie der schwarzen
löcher also als dunkle materie ist ja
das alles voller schwarzer löcher ist
auch sie können wir nicht sehen auch sie
könnten den größten teil der materie
ausmachen und eine solche galaxie ist ja
das absolut den dienst dafür die sterne
sind hier so weit entfernt dass sie nur
wenige und nur kleinere schwarze löcher
bilden konnten nicht mal ein super
massereiches schwarzes loch im zentrum
gibt es passt also alles eigentlich an
genau zu dieser theorie
ich bin mega gespannt was wir alles noch
zur dunklen materie in der nächsten zeit
kommt ich finde es unglaublich spannend
wenn er als erstes neues zu dunkle
materie zu allen anderen themen erfahren
wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
whatsapp das geht hier dann erfahrt ihr
von mir vor allen an land vom neuesten
video garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt
es übrigens darauf whatsapp noch ein
gratis gudi also seid gespannt einfach
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit glocke verkehr
also mit glock genau hier geht es weiter
sie dafür auch draufklicken dunkle
materie rätsel gelöst spielen schwarze
löcher eine rolle da geht es genau um
diese theorie also ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran